joining me now is the Putin fan YouTuber
Jackson the Russian British host of the
trigonometry podcast Constantine kissing
okay welcome to both of you Jackson I
don't get it uh Vladimir Putin invaded
illegally a democratic sovereign country
has rigged total Mayhem he's killed
innocent women children's bomb maternity
hospitals uh he's been on a barbaric
Rampage why would you choose this moment
to Revere him
I would choose this moment because most
of what is said about Vladimir Putin in
the mainstream press by Talking Heads
like yourself is just factually not true
just like everything that people like
you said about covid uh the fact of the
matter is this war that everyone talks
about that so so-called started on
February 24 2022 actually began in 2014
after the U.S led a violent coup on the
Ukrainian government that was
democratically elected when people
specifically ethnic Russians in the Dom
bass decided that they didn't want a U.S
installed puppet government filled with
Nazis they vocalized their opinions and
for that they were met with violence and
aggression by the Ukrainian government
who slaughtered them for eight years
fifteen thousand people died in this
fighting while Putin tried to achieve
peace through the Minsk Accords and the
mince two Accords all of which ended up
being rejected by the Ukrainian
government said the behest of Germany in
the United States
Ukrainian government continue to push
forward despite the fact that Putin
wanted peace and they said that they
wanted to join NATO they said they
wanted to have nukes right on Russia's
border and because of that Putin stepped
in and said hey look we're going to stop
the Bloodshed we're going to stop the
NATO escalation we're going to stop the
risk of potentially this unfolding into
a full-fledged nuclear war and we're
going to do what needs to be done we're
going to liberate the ethnic Russians in
Ukraine we're going to denatify you okay
and we're going to denoxify all right
I'm giving you a good chance to answer
that I've got to say a lot of that I
thought was a Crocker crap but let me go
to Constantine kiss it constantly I find
this attitude completely mind blown
there used to be a time when Americans
in particular certainly conservative
Americans when faced with a choice
between a democratic sovereign country
and a murderous Russian dictator
invading them they wouldn't even
hesitate to support the ukrainians in
this battle what has happened is termed
people like this guy into Putin lovers
who just think he's a man of Peace well
he did say that Putin stepped into and
the Bloodshed which I thought is
interesting given what's been going in
Ukraine for the last year and a half but
actually there's a history I mean first
of all isolationism is a policy that has
had some support in America historically
in fact 1939 1940 there were people
marching up and down Times Square saying
Hitler hasn't done anything to us let's
have peace with Hitler so Jackson's
following in their footsteps there but
you were right in your introduction this
is a very online phenomenon and I was
just in several conservative states in
America West Virginia uh Utah you go
around as Ukraine flags on on most of
the houses there so this is quite a
fringe position but I think uh Jackson
actually alluded to some of the reasons
there is a growing movement of people
who feel that they've been liked to by
the mainstream media quite rightly by
the way particularly over things like
covet yeah and they've developed a sort
of teenage oppositional Defiance
disorder where they now think that the
truth is whatever is the opposite of
what the mainstream is saying and we've
just heard a very good representation of
that I don't know I mean I don't know
where this might mindset takes them I
always say to to conservatives uh who
come up with this kind of stuff well
what did you feel about the invasion of
Kuwait by Saddam Hussein the first one
because they weren't part of NATO QA and
yet the Americans along with the British
raced to throw Saddam Hussein out of
them I get told well he didn't have
nuclear weapons what we thought he did
actually have weapons of mass
destruction
um that whole period but it didn't stop
us doing what was morally the right
thing to do and it's that weird moral
amazed that they've all got themselves
into where they're now defending the
very person that historically
conservatives would have railed against
and a KGB Colonel of course you remember
that too and it's interesting because
one of the arguments people like Jackson
make it's a Pity we've lost them because
I'd love to have more of a debate but
one of the things they seem to think is
that this guy is a representation of the
Christian tradition which is interesting
because uh this is a man who's had
several children out of wedlock with his
mistress and by the way what's
interesting is the people like Jackson
often talk about how under Vladimir
Putin Russia has become this great
country and by the way Putin has
stabilized Russia there's no argument
about that but most of the Elites in
Russia have their children and their
wives in Europe This is interesting
isn't it because they claim that Russia
is this great place on the Vladimir
Putin yet all of those people place
their families outside which is uh tells
you a lot about what they actually think
about the country so uh we've got
Jackson back I think Jackson uh
genuinely the connection went down so
there's no conspiracy we weren't trying
to silence you you no I just find it odd
I mean for argument's sake when Saddam
Hussein invaded Kuwait did you feel that
he was a peace loving guy that we should
be instinctively supporting or did you
agree with American conservatives then
that what should actually happen is
Desert Storm and General Schwarzkopf
should be leading the American charge to
repel him and if you felt the latter why
would you feel differently about someone
like Putin doing this in Ukraine
well I don't know if you know Pierce I'm
only 23 years old so I didn't have fully
fledged opinions on that at the time but
what I think is very interesting is for
all the Western officials that are so
outraged over what Putin is doing in
Ukraine why were they not outrage over
what NATO did to Yugoslavia or what NATO
did to Libya or what the United States
did in Iraq and Afghanistan or Syria the
United States drone operation program in
Africa had a 95 civilian death rate for
everyone to be so up in arms over Putin
liberating these ethnic Russians in
Ukraine from Nazis it is just
Jackson Jackson the trouble is some of
the stuff you said in your initial
response is historically defensible you
can argue from 2014 there's been this
issue there I get that that's a
perfectly reasonable thing to say but
when you say that Putin's only game here
is to go and Liberate the ukrainians
from Nazis you just sound completely
Bonkers Bonkers not say there aren't
some far right people with Nazi
tendencies in Ukraine there are as there
are in many countries but the idea this
is a nazi-run country when the president
is Jewish never mind anything else is
laughably ridiculous
well just because each Jewish doesn't
mean he's not sticking his azov Nazi
thugs on ethnic Russians in the Dom back
you think a Jewish president is going to
be actively promoting Nazism
the ones with swastika tattoos and
Hitler tattoos and Mario for example
here's one question one question what
I'll say is if you're so outraged over
the you know the the atrocities
allegedly of Putin in Ukraine and all
these ukrainians that have been killed
and you tweet about it non-stop why did
you not tweet once about the atrocities
that were perpetrated by the Ukrainian
government from 2014 to 2022 against
those ethnic Russians in the Dom bass
well yeah well I my family are actually
largely ethnic Russians in Ukraine uh
the idea that there's a significant body
of people in Ukraine who by virtue of
being ethnic Russians support what
Vladimir Putin is doing it's complete uh
hogwash frankly
um and the lots of other points that
have been met I mean you're right there
are some far-right elements in Ukraine
as there are in America there's of
Battalion the Jackson's referring to was
formed after Russia invaded in 2014. in
the same way that if Mexico invaded the
United States there'd probably be some
far-right people going out and fighting
there so uh he's got the the whole thing
backwards uh which is not surprising you
know what we could probably explore this
in more detail I mean will Jackson I've
got no desire to censor you to stop you
having your views you're entitled to
them I will challenge them uh We've run
out of time tonight but I think we
should do this again another time uh you
can have a platform here we can talk
about these things because a lot of
people seem to agree with you which I
find baffling but that's the reality so
thank you for joining Piers Morgan on
census night Constantine always good to
see you